hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dungeon nightmares - if
you don't remember dungeon nightmares
won it was a very very scary game that I
played a while back kind of like dread
halls for the oculus rift and it's
bought in the bead blow animation so it
has a very cherished history but anyway
this is the demo for the second one and
I'm gonna play it I just tried it before
yes I don't mind I just stepped into the
world and I'm gonna see if this one
proves to be as scary as the last one
because it actually was pretty jarring
beat me maybe first in January 1 12 p.m.
where am I
awfully odd that it actually is 1st of
January 1:12 and what am I doing here
while I imagine about about to have the
pants karaoke there reason to that is
mr. Slenderman gonna come through there
man that's a game that hasn't played in
a long time Slenderman kind of really
fell out of of notice ok that was the
most ominous drawer I've ever opened in
my entire life I didn't know that every
aspect of this place was haunted I
didn't see anything in there well this
is lovely I love staying at the Bates
Motel really gets my blood flowing when
I want to have a good time I guess I'll
just take a shower yes
alright that works as well just wanted
to make sure everything was properly
functioning or I go complain to the
waitstaff about the demon infestation
hello oh you're moving hello did someone
leave this bear behind why was that R
anomalous noise hey weird painting on
the wall goodness I cannot enter right
now well that's good now I'll write that
down to my dream journal
thump can
oh okay daddy I think the door is stuck
who should I give it a few more whacks I
don't think I can but I might be able to
battle well that says aughts the staff
room okay so that's different so I might
be able to bash that one up and if I
find something that can Club it properly
like my big thick skull hope your body
wasn't in the gutter as I was completing
that sentence everybody you you need to
take a little bit of a breather over
there is a family-friendly horror game
am I seeing things
what why what did I say I didn't see a
damn thing if you tell me I saw
something I'm gonna tell you you lied um
thump okay they're both locked what
about this one ah I know it says I
cannot enter right now but I will unless
that was a warning
why else would I crawl into a rusty
metal box precede a spark of light I
want to be to blow on a beetle oh so
badly oh that was all the precursor I
could have just come down here at any
time looks like I don't have any lights
to spark first effort map wait until you
get off the elevator okay geez I'm sorry
find the artifact and exit can a hotel
is this oh boy it's the bad kind
all right you may not have seen all my
wandering around because now I see how
pointless it all was I may have just
given you something good you know go by
so that you get an idea of the kind of
world worried but we're in the thick of
it now Oh Kate why is this a dip here I
shouldn't ask that looks like a chest in
the first one come on okay well that's
right I got to hold down that right okay
like what is that I should not touch it
why not
what why okay it looks like a bloody
goblet is that what I'm supposed to find
I'm supposed to find treasures I can't
remember if that was actually dred halls
where I was finding treasures or if it
was the other one
ah ah some guy needs to fix that get
some wd-40 on it oh this is dark as hell
the blood looks recent
oh good so glad is this her oh yeah
who's your steam I didn't scare me you
don't scare me
you're a dick bag o CD his candle ok so
it's heavier than it looks
doesn't look that heavy okay all right
this game I think it's good one
I feel true evil when looking at it well
I shan't stare at it because that'd kill
hey buddy hey hey your friend I remember
you you got a lot more detail than last
time okay
beta blow that says beta blow alright
huh oh that is that that is not
convenient at all okay so at least my
volume is way up you need not make my
blood pressure drop
why Godzilla in this building hello
okay you need to calm down a little bit
game because I'm not into this yet you
need to chill axe if that was the thing
about dungeon I what the [ __ ] okay
trying to talk God my light went out I'm
trying to talk it's not giving me the
opportunity to talk alright it's been a
while since I threw myself into a
completely new horror game that's
actually good oh shut up you [ __ ] I
don't want to deal with Thor bumping
around in the walls Oh
oh boy unless it's just two big meaty
demons banging it out not like that
God why is everything I'm saying sexual
right now you know what I mean uh and
maybe you don't know what I mean but
either way it doesn't matter looks like
it goes to a big chamber in here maybe
there's gonna be an artifact in here you
know for a demo it's kind of got the
same stuff going on as the last one but
then again I just remember that dungeon
nightmares one had a bunch nights on it
shut up
bars are something enter okay I'll go
okay sis hooks hooks dangling yeah oh I
should not let the ice phone how can I
help it it to the painting what we got
to do about that oh that's that's a bad
sound okay I got something it's not
polite to stare
I didn't stare okay I learned the lesson
all right so September 13th of September
night what the [ __ ] is that then they're
gamers have my phone that's in the game
screw all of you I didn't even get to
read the rest of the note you all are
sons of [ __ ] in this game shut up
with your dangly goddamn dangly things I
don't like this
squeak yourself to death I'm okay I'm a
little bloody
it's an artifact there's nothing inside
at 1:00 what if it's the severed head of
someone I want okay all right this is a
dead end
it's a goddamn fruitless venture this is
randomly generated so I'm just assuming
this is all gonna be leading me into a
big circle but not intentionally so it's
not intentionally being a dick bag it's
just accidentally leading me astray shut
up goddamn it the Husky um yeah I have
that need to be to blow anything out
nothing that I know that's gonna chase
me and these candles do not last long
there's just a little birthday candles
that I'm carrying around like a twig or
I'm just lighting it's even worse than a
match you know those trick candles that
never go out this one never stays on
okay throw something at me that I didn't
say god damn back off
there's nothing inside I want I'm
willing to bet that they weren't clothes
that were in there even though you said
they uh did he's still there oh you give
me a goddamn second to breathe
oh okay little jittery there but I can
forgive it guys i bugged in this game
you know that yeah two out of ten on
this one oh boy just I don't know if the
Interfax is gonna be in a chest or
something there's gonna be some I'll
carry oh so scared so scared so scared
so ski what a whiny baby
what a big whiny baby Oh little babies
so scared too bad
problems we're all dealing with them
accordingly
in all honesty goddamn I haven't been in
it like this thick and the scarce for a
long time mostly has to do with not
knowing what the hell's gonna happen and
that's awesome and bad Oh what do you
got for me huh we got for me in this big
room yeah big big room big big big big
big big big big means I can run away
from things and they can't possibly kill
me right
keep Oh what all right I keep saying
things and you keep contradicting them
or agreeing with them I don't know oh
hey Tony this game nothing that I want
their blood stains on the inside almost
as if they were drinking blood out of
their blood goblets what else would they
be named for if not for blood maybe he
was just a baby he got hold of a company
spilled it all over the place goddamn
those baby vampires a menace to society
I tell ya guess normal vampires are also
a menace to society please be good oh
this looks good from 3:13 KIAC finally
exit Z exit the way I came back in or
what 313 I'll remember 313 being the
ones that I need to remember is it I
don't know
am I being stalked by something or is
this just this is gonna be happy stroll
back to the exit
I guess Oh should I go back the way I
came is should do something else I guess
I gotta go deeper because it didn't seem
like the elevator was still there when I
came back or when I came here so I doubt
it would let me
thank you stop it you already got me
with that not allowed to give me again I
don't know if I need to go back to the
beginning or what oh god damn in the
dead end stupid dance yeah I'm gonna be
Tablo this just to spite you cuz I
haven't had the chance
what's up ghosts okay I'm out I'm Audi
oh okay go go go go go go go oh where am
I going wherever go Rama go Oh buddy oh
my god what's supposed to go back to the
beginning damn it
oh so noisy just thing no one knows I'm
here right think it'd go this way and
then I go back here through here for
sure this is it and go back up up up to
the winner's circle key awakes who's he
did I wake old man Johnson upstairs is
that the big guy that was thumbing
around this is not gonna work that's not
gonna work is it god damn it damn you
damn you tell Danny and he'll do I do
oh oh okay all right okay I can do this
I'm fine I just need to go back go back
into the hell hole from which I crawled
out of no whispers Emma who's that no
you're not gonna do something to me
uh-uh I can't run
okay I'm run game run where am I going
home again oh my go oh this way I think
yeah yeah this way this way this way
this way
go go go go go go go don't jump out of a
don't a they got me doing don't anything
let anything happen to me because I'm
gonna be just fine
good god this is stressful I don't even
know why nothing's actually happened to
me yet where am I now
halt chains don't look at the chains
chain Sousa mean there's like a thingy
here maybe yes please
yeah yeah it's gotta be it it's gotta be
it hey hey looking at hot girls it okay
let's go pad it's green turn the wheel I
will
oh I'll turn it I'll turn it so good Oh
turning so hard why am I going down why
am I going down why am I going down I'll
stroll to go that way hello oh you [ __ ]
first of January 127 why am I still here
I should check out the room maybe yes
maybe I shouldn't on second thought I
know something about it tells me that
maybe that's not the best idea
alright whatever let's go for it enough
wasting time around here come on what
you got for me come on baby
it's a teddy bear still there yeh still
yeah how's it moving by itself the
questions I want to ask right now oh oh
oh the lights are moving were they
moving before I don't remember but
they're swinging a little bit why cuz
Hulk was smashing up here a little bit
ago come on we're yet I don't have a map
up here I think it might have been down
this way but then again the staff room
was down this way can't exactly see very
well ah 314 ah 330 tada
give me my prize what did I win
okay so so hey
I kick up the beach falls in my way like
okay I can't go down oh no is that the
game you have to open every door oh that
would be horrible oh I would be the
first I gotta go back down go back down
oh crap oh man here I go over and over
hello I heard something there I heard
some can't tell me I didn't hear
something cuz it did okay
very alone this new gig you can't be
serious with this bull you can't be sick
I don't want to go back down in there I
don't wanna I don't want to go okay why
am I going back down I thought this was
just a demo I didn't know that they are
whoa hey
okay fine team uh cool you're funny
you're funny like that
oh hi so scared I understand that
I appreciate you concern well I got
bigger problems okay so anyway this game
does have a save system so I think I can
stop it here and pick it up if you guys
really want me to go again because this
game is good it's game real good so I'm
gonna cut it out before something else
happens to me I actually want to play so
let me know if you want to see more down
in the description below check out the
beatable animation and the original
dungeon nightmares also link down below
or description over there thanks again
everybody and as always I will see
in the next video it's really I pick up
a piece of paper and you tell me to die
isn't that a little extreme here
religions don't follow her to that room
oh really did she hear about me
Jules
you